New immigration rules.
Points will be
to end the use of the health and care visa.
We will stop and seize care workers
from bringing family dependence.
And we will require care firms in England
to be regulated by the Care Quality Commission
in order for them to sponsor visas.
Approximately 120,000 dependents accompanied
100,000 care workers and senior care workers
in the year ending September 2023.
Only 25% of defendant dependents
are estimated to be in work.
Meaning a significant number
or drawing on public services
rather than helping to grow.
His fault. Stop. You.
You're the ones allowed it.
Why you changing it now?
Prime workers do great work in our NHS.
Yeah, because you brought in cheap labor.
That migrants make a big enough financial contribution.
Therefore, we will increase annual immigration
health surcharge this year by 66%.
So they're gonna increase the church and surcharge
to make more money.
And £35 to raise
on average around £1.3 billion.
We only gonna raise if you let them in.
Services of this country.
Every. Literally.
You guys want this?
Second you want it, we will.
Can't you see this, people?
Immigration
undercutting the salary of British workers. Yeah.
We will increase the skilled worker earnings threshold.
You won't allow people to become skilled workers?
38,700 university cost too much.
People are leaving here to go study elsewhere.
With the median full term wage for.
How can British become skilled workers?
Those coming on health and social care visa routes
will Be exempt
so we can continue to bring in the healthcare workers
on which our care sector and NHS rely.
Thirdly, we will scrap
cut price shortage labor from overseas
by ending the 20% going rate salary discount
for shortage occupations
and reforming the shortage occupation list.
I have asked the Migration Advisory Committee
to review the occupations on this list
because of our new
higher skilled worker salary threshold.
About time create a new immigration salary list.
We left it open to exposure
now just because of election
bring dependents who they can support.
So messed up.
Yeah, I agree with that.
Minimum income for family visas to the same threshold
as the minimum salary threshold for skills workers
38,700. The minimum income requirement
of 18,600 has not been increased since 2012.
Okay, speaker,
this package of measures will take place from basically
higher salary people can come in. Finally.
Having already banned overseas master's students
from bringing family members to the UK,
I have asked the Migration Advisory Committee
to review the graduate route
to prevent abuse.
To protect the integrity and quality
of the UK's outstanding higher education sector.
Yeah, but nobody can do the outstanding higher education
because you make it too expensive.
So I need a rich
supporting the pathway into high quality jobs
for the global talent pool
but reducing opportunities for abuse.